from above casaldi principe may look
like a normal town
but whenever fabio stabile comes to his
old neighborhood it awakens painful
memories
the ruins of demolished houses bring to
mind his own fate
whether it's a friend's house or his
family's
his home where his parents siblings and
their four children used to live stood
behind this fence
but a few months ago excavators rolled
up on orders from the public
prosecutor's office
[Music]
on september 2nd the government
destroyed our lives
one of my brothers and his four children
now live in social housing
their home ended up being torn down
because fabio stabile's father had built
it without a permit over 20 years prior
the town didn't even have an official
urban development plan until 2006 so
building permits were rare
when we bought this property
we were told
after a few months my father talked to
the local government at the time
and asked if construction could resume
first they let us build
now they're tearing it all down again
that can't be right
when i see this it tears me up inside
and they're not alone
the entire district was built from
scratch illegally
these streets often don't exist in the
official plans because the camora even
had control over the town hall for
decades
until anti-mafia activist renato natale
became mayor of casal de principe in
2014.
with
they couldn't rely on a single
whole construction sector
the public prosecutor's office has
ordered 1 300 houses to be demolished in
casal de principe alone and over 200 000
throughout campania this incendiary
decision could cost thousands of people
their homes
but olga marino and dominico esposito
are fighting back with their group
casamia or my house
we founded this association to protect
the homes we built for ourselves
and our children
they've been organizing protests for
months and now count over 3 000 members
among their ranks
we call on anyone living in a house set
to be demolished to demonstrate with us
in front of the parliament in rome
why aren't they tearing down houses
built by speculators or the kamura
only everyday people's homes are being
destroyed
the government ought to be ashamed of
itself for how it's treating us
families homes like these must not be
demolished we want
the government to sit down with us
and figure out an acceptable solution
because the biggest winners will be the
kamora who will seek to come to the
rescue of residents in need
people in such dire straits are very
desperate under easy prey for the camara
because a hopeless situation can lead
them to make desperate decisions
and so the mayor has taken the activist
side it would cost his municipality
alone 35 million euros to tear down the
illegally constructed homes and the
local government doesn't have that kind
of
but it may take a while for the
government to put this proposal into
action in the meantime excavators
continue to tear down illegally
constructed houses like fabio stabiles
and his neighbors and not just in casal
de principe
you